el kurdistán iraníes digamos de los del
distintos regiones que se que conforman
lo que es el curistan es como la más
pequeña pero
ciertamente la el régimen de la
República islámica ha tenido una
relación bastante complicada con con
algunos grupos kurdos particularmente
en el partido democrático del curistan
iraní que no sólo se considera ilegal
sino que además se considera un grupo
bueno el régimen lo consideró un grupo
terrorista y sus operativos en realidad
operan desde Irak que es justamente lo
que presumiblemente atacaron con drones
desde Irán
sí y qué representa exactamente este
kurdistán en ir aquí para estos grupos
Es un punto de convergencia de Unión de
varios grupos y perdón kurdos fuera de
las fronteras de Irán
Sí también hay que tomar en cuenta que
el kurdistán y de aquí que es en el
norte de Irak es una zona pues bastante
Autónoma que está gobernada por
varios partidos políticos que son muy
muy estrechos colaboradores de Estados
Unidos entonces para Irán también el
hecho de que haya
kurdos iraníes colaborando con estos
grupos que a su vez colaboran con
Estados Unidos pues Por supuesto que que
causan todo tipo de sospechas y por eso
en este momento a pesar de que
claramente las protestas son por
demandas sociales muy legítimas el hecho
de esta asociación entre los curistas
los kurdos iraníes y Estados Unidos y en
los partidos del coristanel aquí da el
pretexto para decir que que esto es todo
un asunto de de traído desde el
extranjero
si sin embargo la relación de los
barzani los dirigentes del kurdistán
iraquí con el peca cal partido de los
trabajadores del kurdistán a quienes se
enfrentan junto a Turquía y también con
las ipg y PJ de Siria es algo más
turbulenta que se debe esta
diferenciación con los diferentes grupos
kurdos
después de que
el kurdistán el proyecto de un estado
curvo termino de no cuajar lo que sucede
es que se van fragmentando las distintas
facciones políticas la facción liderada
por
oyalan en Turquía y mayoritariamente en
el norte de Siria terminó tomando un
cariz político e ideológico muy distinto
al que eventualmente tomó los barsanis
en el norte de Irak entonces con el
pasar del tiempo y también en el inter
pasamos por la Guerra Fría hubo un
distanciamiento muy muy sustancial al
grado que los barsani se encontraron en
una acomoda mucho más
benéfico incluso con Turquía que con Por
supuesto
que lo que podemos decir con con zurdos
en Turquía y en Siria pero sobre todo
tiene que ver con un distanciamiento en
términos ideológicos en Irán nunca se
pudo consolidar un partido kurdo Sólido
y efectos prácticos desde los 80s los
los expulsaron a la